she's a British entrepreneur and leader
she co-founded the lingerie company
Ultimo and the fake tanning Company you
ten she has an estimated net worth of
sixty million dollars
she's Michele Mon and here her top ten
rules for success I think that I watched
on my fringe lunge and dodge redundant
and I thought I want to be in charge of
her company and you know I went to meet
people's lives happy instead of always
meeting them what it Christmastime am I
gonna have a job to buy toys for my kids
I named I thought you know it doesn't
matter
excuse me if you're born into royalty or
you're born into money I'm going to show
people that you know someone from the
East End he hasn't done well at school
can still make something of their life
you know it doesn't need to see that
you're from the East End the Glasgow
that you're going to be a joke loser and
you're going to be just no key to
anything I wanted to show people that
you know we are all human beings it
doesn't matter we were born we were
brought up how much money our families
have got you can make something of your
life because you're in charge of your
life and I think that's what what what
drives me I just think that you know my
mom and dad's brought me up and and
taught me to have respect for anyone no
matter if you're the queen no you into
the bed
and everyone is special and I think that
just appreciate like yeah I never think
in negative ways because negative things
will happen if you want to achieve
something write down your goals and if
it doesn't work out it's your own fault
okay do it do it right it's got to do
something that makes you passionate that
makes you tick that makes you get up in
the morning that makes you get to your
sleep at night if you have to yeah like
I did last night make sure that you're
doing something cuz you're know if once
yeah and you you will know what makes
you happy and st. and go with that and
then it's a key so you've got to you
know put whatever in bit tEEX yeah to
get it done
my mum and dad always taught me when I
was growing up that you cheat people how
you want cheated yourself and I think
that's the best thing that we ever
taught me ma'am because I never treat
people badly and unfairly and I always
treat them with respect and then that's
you know I think okay I've got such a
fantastic team they really are all
enthusiastic and attempt if you've got
that idea you know that it's all about
believing in yourself first of all if
you've got a confidence and you believe
it and you know in your heart I can do
this that's all it really takes then the
other things come the business plan the
financing of it the idea we are going to
manufacture or if it's a service that
you're going to provide all of these
things come but first of all you've got
to believe in yourself you've got to
want to do it if you don't want to do it
don't even start it if you've got to go
out then you've got to approach people
don't ever sit there and wait for
someone to come to you because I'll tell
you it will never happen you've got to
look for your non-pitcher
never to see this is what I want to do
therefore who's your customers you know
what markets you want to go into who's
your competitors rate a really strong
business as well what keeps my feet
firmly on the ground is that you know I
have that the back in my lane that I
could lose it all tomorrow and then you
know you should never get too big for
your boots and I'm doing this not just
for my family but I'm doing it to help
others as well because I want to help
people who are you know not so fortunate
as I am and the places that I was
brought up in because I know what
poverty is you know I've been at one end
of the state to the other
I've been there where you don't have any
money and you don't have a bath and all
the rest of it and I've been partying on
boats for that's a branching and famous
singers and actresses and you know it so
I know what both signs of life are and I
just want to help others as much as I
can trying to feel and I'm always a
planner August keyless always carry a
book in my bag what I need to do today
with personally and both in business and
I stay focused on that list and I try
and take every single day off and if I
don't you know I'm not super women I've
got three children I'm not the best best
nice women in the planet but I just try
my best if I don't manage to do anything
on the list then I take it forward to
the next day I fight every single day in
business I start new ideas every single
week and I think what drives me you
should don't get me wrong
money used to drive me but then when you
pass by some of these you know goals at
your cheese it goes on to another level
and it's weird to explain it and it's
hard to explain it but I think it's a
fear of failure that keeps me going and
always wanting to make a difference for
my customers always wanting to give them
the best fit the best quality and you
have just started up Ultima Beauty
Altima u-turn worked on our new tanning
products new street no smell of biscuits
etc it's launched in Boots Debenhams
Xhosa foods are having across Harrods
all over and I just love the challenge
and you know I try and keep it real I'm
doing my best to keep it real because
you know there's another beggar abort -
Missy much bigger than than me and I
still still believe that I have not made
it yet I don't believe I've made it yet
if I always had a dream and my dream was
to be big in business and I always
always believed that it doesn't matter
where you're from it doesn't matter what
background you have it doesn't matter
education you know you've got to try
your best but my situation I it wasn't
for me
so I left school at 15 with a dream and
I always always think big you should
always think big in life never ever
think that you can't make it because
others out there are better than you
you're just as good as anyone else thank
you so much for watching I made this
video because Twiggy Monet asked me to
so if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know which of
Michelle's top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching
continues to believe and I'll see you
soon